it is the most mysterious number in the
Bible 6 6 6 some think it's the mark of
the beast but is that what the bible
really says ancient Pagan priests used
to wear a solar seal with six columns
and six rows all the numbers in each
column or row adding up to this
intriguing number where does this number
come from what are its Origins and what
does it mean for the end of time this is
the origins of 666
James Alex welcome back to the show you
guys recently came on to the show and
you talked about the origins of the
Jesuits and like open up their books
from 400 years old and that video ended
up in the top 10 of our videos for the
whole year and now you're back to talk
about 666 and the origins of 666 I mean
this is going to be a wild ride now is
it a
microchip I don't think so right what do
you think Alex spiler aler is it a
tattoo no no it's not spoiler alert
James tell us it's something a lot
deeper really striking at the core of
Christianity in its blasphemy but you
know to really understand that we got to
go back to ancient Babylon uh you know
the Babylon religion was a very much a
solar religion and there were six houses
in the Zodiac with three rooms a piece
in that the sun was thought to pass
through in the daytime and six houses
with three rooms of Peace at night so 36
houses in total one of the things that I
find interesting about their math is if
you add up 1 plus 2 plus three all the
way up to 36 what do you suppose that
adds up to 66 I did not know that wow
was fascinating so you know as part of
their solar religion the sun worshipping
religion it was very much associated
with the number 666 and that's the
problem with a lot of modern
interpretations is they take the number
but they have no understanding yes
exactly no Contex right you you know uh
one of the things that we find is
actually Rome you know who Peter
identified as
Babylon uh was originally called the
city of Saturn and it was vouched alike
by ID plyy unelius
Victor that you know uh if you look here
at the name Saturn or uh the names that
the letters in it that actually add up
to Value you end up with st and St adds
up to 666 what oh and this is with the
Roman numerical system right this in
Latin this would be in uh Greek if I
remember correctly here but in the
ancient in the ancient gatria this name
would add up to
666 and you know one of the things Keith
I think you've seen these before do you
remember what these are yeah I saw these
in a class I took on the Book of
Revelation and um the little Matrix here
with all the
numbers um at least what I remember and
you guys can correct me if I'm wrong but
it seemed like they add added up uh if
you take a row or a column or a diagonal
they would add up to
666 interesting too that on the coin on
the left there's a Sun at the top and
then there's the Star of David all
around but I think you were you were
saying before on these what it looks
like and and I have to go back to my
notes I me could be totally wrong I
think you were saying they add up to 111
and there're six rows so each makes a
whole lot more sense yes each line going
across and each line going down adds up
to 111 and so the sum total of the six
rows of 111 adds up to 666 otherwise
it's random random numbers in each box
but they in totality add up what so are
they all always the same with the same
numbers in the same place or would I
just mix them up no I mean if you look
at this one well over here the one on
the the left down at the bottom has a
six in the top left this one has a one
in the top left interesting and and note
how prominent you know you got soulless
it's like a reference to the sun it's
it's very prominent in these these were
said to be or thought to be like good
luck amulets that you would carry and
give you good luck there's this Hindu
god I'm pretty sure it's Shiva and Shiva
if you understand it is actually a
reference to
Satan um and it has a lot of
similarities to Satan at least in in in
the myth mythology of that you know we
see this featured though in modern
Babylonian religion so one of the things
that that you might be familiar with is
a monstrance and it's
this uh basically this piece of art that
looks like a sun and you've got these
these Sun like the ray yeah the Rays
coming up but look right there stigma D
gamma stigma in the Greek that's 666 so
s where do you see that right here it
looks like SFS oh right right right yeah
stigma D gamma stigma that that would be
666 right there featured on the monstr
what what is this used for uh this would
be you might see a monstrance very
commonly carried like in Catholic mass
so they carry it Forward actually during
the height of the pandemic you might
remember that video of Pope Francis
going out there for Co and holding this
big Golden Sun you know out like oh yeah
I've seen that before yeah he was just
holding it out and like you know showing
it all around well right there on some
of these monstrances you have the stigma
D gamma stigma which is 666 and this is
Babylonian originally yeah going back to
ancient Babylon you know there's a lot
of things that are in with Babylon
though like these are the Bale worship
stones of hazor and you see that little
symbol over there m it looks like a
charot wheel almost right uh very solar
in its origin you can see a similar one
here on the lra uh in the coins MH and
which is from the Roman Catholic Church
yeah mhm 1929 wow yeah this is from the
SI Del
vaticano or the city of the Vatican but
there's a lot of things in common with
ancient Bale worship and Babylon and
that's you know that's uh one thing I
think a lot of people don't realize
today what do you guys see right here in
this is the water basin of assour what
are some things that you're seeing in
this picture isn't this Deon Keith well
it looks like Deon at least I mean it it
could be I can't tell I see Fish Heads
kind of right there yeah it looks like
fish heads yeah see fish tail the fish
miter scales yeah look at the crown on
the king how many how many tiers are
there there's three tiers triple Tiara
and then there's the asper Gillum so
they're they're you know dousing in the
holy water very similar right here you
can see the asper Gillum and the the
fish miter for Nimrod so the I I think
is this oh this is Nimrod mhm Yep this
is uh which is this the go the no the
God is Not Nimrod is it yeah this was
Nim as a God right interesting okay
because I know that in the Bible it
talks about Deon which was worshiped by
the Philistines and they also had the
yeah very much connected back uh here we
can see the SR hoden for example aelle
and over here on the right you can see
that triple Tiara and you can also see
right here the little Sun thing on the
wrist yeah pal right there yep
exactly and you know this this idea of
solar worship and the sun you see
actually the largest solar wheel in the
world right here in St Peter's fail like
the
square but the
Israelites burned the Chariots Wheels
like the of the Sun and they destroyed
them because they were an Abomination to
God Sun worship was opposed to True
Religion but you know ultimately one of
the things you mentioned is the dragon
right did you guys know that the dragon
is featured very prominently at the
Vatican did not know that so this is
right here you've got in the Vatican
gard's actually a statue of the Dragon
himself spewing out
water and I got to wonder where do we
get our water
from spiritually speaking from from the
Bible yeah right that isn't isn't Christ
The Water of Life right you know but
here they've got the Vatican in the
Vatican you've got this Dragon that's
spewing out water but these are some of
the identifiers so what we're going to
do is kind of build on those identifiers
what do warning do have in Revelation
17 you know that's another connecting
Factor here in Bible prophecy as we
identify the number and name is we got
to understand all of these prophetic
identifiers that cohesively come
together in in one picture was the
mother of all churches yeah and here at
St John of Lan right outside there's an
inscription where the mother church is
identified mhm yeah omnium urbus at
orbus eum M at kaput what does it mean
well it means Supreme mother of churches
the the sacred lattern Church
universally for the city and the world
Supreme mother of churches yeah R 17
talks about the mother of the harlots
right in fact you know they've even used
very similar language to that Pope
Francis in 2014 stated that the
Cathedral of Roman which tradition
defines as mother of all churches of the
city and of the world so there's this
mother Church
and you know vaticanus itself actually
the name if you break down the Latin you
got Vates and you got anus so Vates
meaning prophecy anus meaning Old Maid
or old woman so putting it together
you've got old woman of Prophecy in fact
even in the old Latin uh Proverbs like
anus sub mum excited pis the old woman
dancing stirs up dust so this was um you
know the word anus was actually long
associated with old woman so vaticanus
old woman of Prophecy and it's
interesting how this woman is depicted
as holding a golden cup in Revelation 17
you mean yeah and they actually put that
on their numismatics their coins let's
take a look at Leo the 12th right here
so here you have this woman holding a
golden cup Seated on the world set at
Super universum her seat of authority is
universal wow and she's having the sun
around her exactly yeah exactly so um
how many of you guys have have you guys
ever heard of any other numbers besides
666 like some people talking about 616
no I have heard that
before but yeah I think the Bible's
pretty
clear and I don't know it's kind of a
weird thing A friend of mine always
pointed out he's like tend to find
numbers in the Bible at least more than
once mhm like it's just not usually all
by itself so like even those 666 is in
Revelation you also find it
um oh is it Second Kings with Solomon
yeah you know bringing in 666 talents of
gold you know brought in every year like
so so why why do people think 626 well
the reason is is that 616 oh 616 yeah
yeah irus um actually recognized that
there was a copyist error and so 616 it
kind of crept in as a copyist error but
there's a lot of people today that still
try and use that to come to a conclusion
even though those who had spoke to the
Apostle John face to face said it was
666 and he himself actually applied it
to the Latins and identified the Latinos
as the the name he thought added up to
666 referring to the Latin power and so
you know as we build on this idea aidea
of a name a Blasphemous name adding up
to 666 we've got to understand that 2
Thessalonians 2:4 and the rest of
scripture identify that there would be a
man of sin who comes in and use
Blasphemous names so if we're building
our case a modus operand Blasphemous
names let's take a look at some other
Blasphemous names that this power has
used well that's a good point and I and
I was hoping we would touch on that just
a little bit
is you can't just use the number for
anything or anybody it has it's it's a
very specific use case where it applies
so a lot of
people like to take numbers and make
anything and everything out of them but
it's it's like throwing darts at a dart
board essentially you know you can you
can essentially make it almost whatever
you want you probably heard of things
like the Bible Code and you know and
other things like that and it's like
well you know then then Abraham Lincoln
or whatever we 66 or 666 or whatever and
that's not what the Bible's referring to
but the Bible gives like a constellation
of different points and you have you
can't just take one point and point you
have to look at the overall picture and
not miss the force for the trees y yeah
you know 2 Thessalonians 2:4 in the
vgate talks about the man of sin showing
himself and but that's the same word
Austin detour used here in canon law
that it was quite clearly shown that the
pontiff cannot be bound by the secular
power which is evid L called a God by
the pious Prince Constantine and this
was a consistent theme throughout
Catholic documents for example we see
right here where Archbishop of carfu
Christopher marceles said to Pope Julius
II and the fifth leran Council Thou Art
finally another God on
Earth we can see that right here in
multiple manuscripts where also uh Simon
begus the bishop of madr regarding Leo
the 10th actually referred to this lion
the tribe of Judah instead of as Christ
pointed it to the pope blessed Leo as
the Savior that was to come because his
name was Leo right right yeah and King
of Kings you know another lion the king
of
quadrupeds this was applied to once
again belthasar Del R applied this at
the seventh latter in session to the
pope for all power is given unto thee
Pope Leo and in heaven and in Earth and
you know they use this idea of we hold
upon the Earth the place of God almighty
this Vatican assassin right here ravic
actually said the pope is God and God is
the pope what right yeah this is so
bizarre yeah is so this is when this was
written so 1611 the same year the the
King James was published yeah yeah
exactly yeah Spanish Cardinal cardelus
and his defense of Trent they make him
into a great pontiff or rather into an
earth Earthly and mortal
God uh or this one this was actually an
inscription on a triumphal Arch erected
in honor of the Pope by the Oracle of
the voice of the world You Will Rule and
you will rightly Merit to be called a
God on in the earth I mean I'm many
Commandments are are they breaking by
just making all those statements yeah
seriously yeah Cornelio muso said that
who is to us God in things that concern
God as God himself or Mar uh this was
Lucius ferreras right here as to paper
Authority the pope as it were God on
Earth sole Sovereign of all the faithful
of Christ Chief King of Kings having a
plenitude of unbroken power in trusted
by the omnipotent God to govern the
Earthly and Heavenly
kingdoms and you know these are these
are you know people talk about well what
did the magisterium say but this is you
know individuals from the magisterium
who are referring to the pope as the
Vicor of God who alone is called Most
Holy hence the pope is crowned with a
Triple Crown Reckoning back to Babylon
there is king of heaven and of Earth and
of
hell and you know they went so far in
this as to say that every cleric must
obey the pope even if he commands what
is wrong for no one can judge him the
only exception was if the command
involved heresy or tended to the
destruction of the church but you know
if you really go back to what the Pope
here is referencing and this is innocent
I 4th right here you can go back and
take a look at distiny Authority what
he's referencing in canon law where it
actually went so far as to say that the
pope could lead the entire world to hell
and no mortal May presume to rebuke him
because he is to judge all and no man
him that that is so bizarre it's such a
misrepresentation of God for for one
like they're all saying he is God
secondly he's wearing a Triple Crown
indicating well I am God and I rule over
all these areas which god Jehovah rules
in actual fact um and then he's like
well yeah nobody can judge me even if I
lead people to hell but that's not what
the real God is like he's like I want to
lead people to Heaven I want to save
people I've come to die for you and in
this in this system they're saying well
I am God I'm putting myself in the place
of God which is literally what Satan did
when and then that's the reason why he
was cast out of Heaven because he wanted
to take the Throne of God and he's doing
the exact same thing something just hit
me crowned King Of Heaven Earth hell can
you guys think of a commandment in God's
law where God's Authority is recognized
for those yeah I was thinking that the
fourth Commandment yeah right is naming
all the the territory of dominion yeah H
yeah I guess what's what's fascinating
to me is it's like it's it's so
backwards it's like saying well he can
because he is God he can do
wrong instead of looking at the
scriptures would say you know God is
light in him is no Darkness all know I'm
God I cannot lie even God isit like I
can't it's impossible for me to go
against my word my law because I myself
my law my word they're all the same so
it's not like well because I'm the most
powerful I can do whatever I want no God
is like no I'm still Bound by those
Eternal things which represent me m and
then
also going off of that Satan's law
according to Satan is Al Crowley is do
what thou Wilt shall be the whole of the
law which is what this is but God like
you said is it cannot go against his own
law and Commandments and he says Love
Thy Neighbor love as you love yourself
and love God supremely yeah they you
know they keep going that it's not man
but God separates Those whom the Roman
pontiff not of a mere man but of true
God having weighed the necessity of the
benefit of the true church is dissolves
not by human but rather by Divine
Authority Rome was great under Caesar
but now she is greatest Alexander the
six Reigns the former was a man the
latter is a God and that was you know
Rodrigo uh one of the one of the
triumphal arches that erected in his
honor stated you know I've I've been
recently digging into the Vatican
digital library though because these are
some of like the really old medieval
manuscripts stuff that really it's
really hard to locate stuff in and we're
finding that some of these quot quotes
that were talked about I know you guys
have talked about the book The Great
controversy before um it referenced this
quote Lord God the Pope in great
controversy page 50 and I actually found
that statement here in the Vatican
Digital Library in extravagantes vat.
lat. 1397 you can go to folio 166 V and
there it is dominum deum nostrom poam
yeah and this is public information
everybody can go there and find it yes
anybody can go there I mean there
there's the you just go to The Dig live
and you can type in that reference right
there and go to the folio and this was
actually in a gloss of extravagantes but
as we've seen this was used in canon law
and Elsewhere for you know many
documents but you can see right here
that this was included in multiple
editions of this document including the
corrected adito Romano version so that
the pope actually signed off on so so
this was a gloss that was you know very
much recognized as hey that's that's
doctrinally sound how did they get
around the first commandment thou shal
not have any other gods before me how do
they how do they come to a reckoning of
that did they just completely ignore it
or what well they believe that power was
passed on to Peter and that Peter was
constituted the Vicor of the Son of God
or the Vicor of Christ the replacement
of Christ and so they have authority to
when they say bind and loose binding and
loosing for them means the ability to
change the law of God so so first they
say Peter replaced Jesus H and then they
say after Peter it's the popes who are
the Vigor of the sum so then by that
logic they would say Peter is a God then
right because if they're saying the pope
is a God and if every Pope is a god they
would say that Peter is a God you have
to you have to
right well they say even though he was
corrupt in his morals the pope should be
called holy and most holy and so you
know one of the things that crept in one
of the high work high watermarks of
papal pretentions was this forgery known
as the Don of Constantine it was later
revealed as a forgery and you know it
was supposedly this document passed down
from Constantine that gave the pope
Authority in the church and they wanted
to establish their legal Authority the
interesting thing about it is is when
that was found to be a forgery they took
the fellow who founded laurentius Vala
and his work exposing it as a forgery
they actually prohibited at the Council
of Trent on the donation
the index lium prohibitorum because they
didn't want the whistle being blown that
they had actually relied on a forgery
well because that's they relied on that
to give them authority to rule yeah so
don't anybody question us and so what we
find is these terms vicarius fil
vicarius Christi all throughout
documents that's a lot of documents
these are just a few this is just a tiny
fraction of what was out there and how
many of you guys well have you guys
heard of this this fellow before Andreas
helig no no can't say that I have okay
so he published this work anti Christos
Romanus he was the first major
Protestant author in 1612 to actually
recognize that there was one title and
the way he did this is he went through
Cardinal barman's uh identifiers for
what the name like should be he used the
basically the the catholic's own
identifiers and said well hey there is a
title that fulfills all of your
identifiers it is vicarius filad so
hundreds of years ago Protestants knew
this name added up to 666 and and you
had the uh some the old um Geneva Bible
that the people from the Mayflower used
who fled persecution from Roman Catholic
Church they came to the United States
and they had a commentary in there that
you guys showed us in the previous
episode about the Jesuits that we did um
that said that they believed that the
Christ was the papal system or the yes
do you guys remember what did uh what
did Peter confess that Christ
was you are the Christ the son of the
Living God yeah the son of living God
right so think about this the very
confession that Peter has the devil
wants to come along and counterfeit by a
replacement for the Son of God of a
Vicor of the Son of God exact it's it's
such a play on on Peter's confession
so you have this is Roman numerals here
yeah yeah this these are how they add up
and and you and v as the same number
right yes and that's something anybody
who spent any length of time reading
Latin documents you know that un and V
are interchangeable and I've actually
got some examples of that now some
people say well it's not an official
title we're going to look at that but um
you know the other title vicarius Cristy
that's commonly used if you open your
Bible to Leviticus 24:18 he that kth a
beast shall make it good Beast for Beast
now the make it good in the Latin is
viarum the Beast for Beast okay when
you're using it for you're using it in
the substitute sense here is anti mhm so
the substitute the viarum is the anti
Antichrist antichristus viarum Christi
it's essentially the same thing wow it
literally means they both mean in place
of Christ right so exactly I mean yeah
now uh you know there's been a lot of
people that have witnessed actually
several people who have witnessed that
there was a a tiara that added up to 666
or or or had that title had that title
on it this is one witness right here
there's another witness this was balasar
Hoffman this is his Vatican passport
right here but he actually wrote a
document um testifying the fact that he
saw this now whether or not this is true
you know they've had hundreds of years
to take take this and say well let's you
know let's move this out of sight but
nevertheless there were even Catholic
papers like our Sunday visitor who
stated the letters inscribed on the
Pope's smer are these vicarius fil so
they've said this themselves and went so
far as to say that there is no
inscription on the Triple Crown of the
popes as anyone who will take the
trouble to examine the photographs of
The Tiara can easily determine for
himself and you know there's others who
have disagreed now see they said this
here in contradiction to the previous
document because there were some
questions that were being brought up so
so basically what you're saying is is
they've tried to deny that vicarious
philli de has been used yeah despite the
hundreds of uses over the many hundreds
of years that have been there um and so
they put it on their Tiara and then they
admited it's on the Tiara and then later
when they start getting heat for it they
say oh no there's actually nothing
written on the tra at all right and they
admit that vicarius fil is no different
from vicarius Christi because after all
if you're really honest with it fil the
Son of God is Christ
chrisy they're answering their own
question yeah yeah cuz he says uh why
would he have it
inscribed he says it's an admission
right there yeah exactly in fact the the
head chaplain of Catholic answers back
in 2013 I happened to grab these screen
shots of uh TCA Faith online April 5th
in 2013 and there somebody asked the
question what are the words inscribed on
the Pope's miter and what do they
signify and Ray Ryland States the words
are vicarius f e so they've admitted it
now we don't have pictures of all of the
Tiaras because they've kind of hid some
of them but remember that yeah exactly
do you remember that claim well there's
no words inscribed on the miter well
actually here's the Belgium tiara from
the ladies of gent and it actually is
inscribed and we've got a video in fact
of Steven colar touring the Met Gala and
actually seeing this so let's take a
look at that Anna Andrew what are we
about to see uh we're about to see some
Treasures from the Vatican collection
and from the sine Chapel
sacy all right I want to see some of
this stuff some of this beautiful stuff
there it is yeah I don't know if you
guys saw that there you might have to
slow it down but right there you can see
that there's an inscription on it now um
back a few years ago in
1943 there were some individuals who
went to the Catholic University of
America and spoke with their lead
scholar Dr Johannes Quon and asked him
about vicarius filad he actually wrote
this on a piece of paper the title
vicarius filad as well as the title
vicarius Christi is very common as the
title of the
Pope I mean there all saying it exactly
so if you go to Revelation then
Revelation 13:18 where it's talking
about you know some translations will
say the number of a man others will say
the the number of the name actually so
if you take the title that adds up to
666 and it's very commonly used as he is
you know saying right here and you put
it all together I mean it's it fits
perfectly with the prophetic narrative
yeah all of the identifiers are there
here's the Vatican Council and its
definitions this one's a cardinal
Manning right here Vicor of the Son of
God Vicor of Jesus Christ so that's the
English usage of it but you know many
popes use this Pope Leo the9th in the
1913 Catholic ency
encyclopedia um we can see actually
there's there's a discussion of it in in
Terra Pac homeini boo in 1054 here is
the title right here and you can see the
letter to konus the tartar in 1289 Pope
Nicholas iv used this title as well and
here we've got one of the main documents
in by a Canon lawyer augustinus
triumphus now this was kind of uh a very
pretentious document that talked a lot
about the authority of the Pope and it
was kind of a high Watermark document in
the Middle Ages but it had vicarius fil
throughout it and establishing that as
as an authoritative title you know one
of the things that I find interesting
though is is you see this in the we
talked about thison yeah it's another
dragon now it's gilded yeah Golden
Dragon what what is gold a symbol of
when you have the Ark of the Covenant
you've got gold and you've got wood
right so what is golden wood a symbol of
if you think of like the Ark of the
Covenant if that's representative of
Christ Christ had maybe the wood and the
gold what would what would it be in that
context I'm thinking of like maybe the
two Natures of
Christ you mean like the wood of the
Cross or the you've got Divinity and
you've got Humanity right mhm okay and
in the early church one of the things
that I mean that was one of identifiers
that they use but here they're using
gold symbolic of divinity for the dragon
that's very bizarre yeah it's it's
interesting but you know I mentioned
that document augustinus triumphus
here's a copy of it printed by this Pope
who's got the dragon as his seal and in
this document one of the things that
they did is a twofold they referred to
the pope as vicarius filad but they've
also argued for his authority to change
Sabbath Sunday yeah I was looking and I
could see yeah sabath interesting and
I've actually just uh located this
document in one of those much older
manuscripts on the Vatican Digital
Library so there's there's more coming
that's hand printed yes this is some of
the handprinted stuff that you can find
in the individual folios on the Vatican
digital Library there's vicarius fil
right there vtor constitut yeah so the
pope is constituted or Peter constituted
vicarius fil it's about as authoritative
a statement as you could get yeah where
this Pope you know uh the pope is
constituted basically declared legally
by law that he is vicarius
fil and the pope who actually put
together this copy right here who has
the Dragon as his as his seal is the
very one that celebrated the St
Bartholomew's Massacre no we have uh we
have one of those coins yeah this is
something that you guys also showed in
the last episode about the Jesuits but
but basically this is like common money
that was around for like hundreds of
years right they kept restriking it yeah
so it's like if I just went to the
grocery store and I just wanted to buy a
lollipop I used that it's like it's like
today Biden has his face in one hand
side and the other side it's like the
mass murder of a group of people it
would be like Putin celebrating the
Ukraine crisis you know and then just
like using as common money for hundreds
of years are those it looks like little
cherubs at the top yeah is that supposed
to be like the Ten Commandments in each
of their hands or so they're holding the
uh oh you talking on the sides yeah at
the very top hm I'm not sure actually I
know that we've got two here in the
middle holding those keys together
for the seal that's very commonly known
interesting fact the red cord that binds
those together is symbolic of church and
state uniting well you also see the tiar
up there ruler of you know right Heaven
Earth and
Hell yep they got everything on
there there's uh there's another bull
right here Pope John the 22nd in 1322
use the term vicarius filad so we're
going through not just canon law but
papal usage lawyer usage everybody used
this title so what's it say below that
because it looks like the word Sabbath
is in there somewhere yeah satina satina
yeah so this is the bull of sabatina
where John 20 John the 22nd affirmed an
Indulgence for members of the carate
order wearers of the scapular of the
lady of of Mount Carmel known as the
brown scapular and they were promised to
be quickly freed from the the Flames of
purgatory at least by the Satur after
their
death so it was yeah it was it was a
bull how kind dealing with that but
isn't that interesting that we know that
in a lot of
languages you Saturday they usually use
Sabbath for the word Saturday even in
the Latin they say sabatina that sounds
like Sabbath to me well sabbatum
sabbatum is the Sabbath or sabti in
Latin yeah so Lum in 1327 again using
the same vicarius fil you can see it
right right here featured you've got
this is another copy of it right here
but even in recent times so you can go
to the vatican's website right now been
there yep rivy munis 1965 and Baff
1968 viar proc is like one of the
opening phrases like the opening name
for the pope given on these you know
constitutions the apostolic Constitution
Baff
and we're going to go through just
briefly this is a a Christian religionis
thesaurus by the Venetian lawyer alonsus
Guero and he used it in his uh thesaurus
you've got zetti using this in his
consilium as well and of course torima
you guys might have heard of Tada with
the Inquisition right so Tada um this
was actually one of his
relatives uh Tom Juan de tooma actually
who used this term in his work as well
and there was the Archbishop of Florence
in
1581 you've got Edward Manning another
Catholic Cardinal actually using the
title
there and you've got the Vindication
against the popes of vindication of the
popes against opponents of all kinds by
vbal Heist using the title here are you
guys getting a picture here that this is
like not an official title or is it
something that's used very widely seems
like they use it a lot yeah right y so
I've got just a few more here this is
the Jesuit Vincent HRI the polyantha
srum by P Vini and lenus brancati you've
got Wulf gain fre in his work who is
Peter so literally defining who Peter
actually is and his statement once again
is fil vicarius but I I think I think
Peter when when we all get to heaven
after the second coming of Christ yeah
Peter is going to be like you do
what what happened I think Mary will
probably say the same thing oh yeah
Mary's like wait wait wait wait wait
that was not I I I distan myself from
that yeah you know it was actually even
included in a French catechism so here's
the catechism right here in French in
1845 and and there it is
viar and in French and Lucius Ferraris
we've got
Theologian who used it we've got even
Pope John Paul 2 himself using it Vicor
of Jesus Christ and the pope uh is the
one who takes the place of the Son of
God of the second person of the God and
this is interesting thing we had the
Holy Spirit Come when Jesus left but
even in that sense he didn't take his
place he wasn't replacing Jesus Jesus is
still Jesus but he is uh another part
part of the godhead that came to Earth
to help us come closer to God but it's
not like the holy spirit is saying I am
now Christ right it's they're still
individual parts of the godhead this is
interesting statement I was just kind of
quickly reading through it and uh he's
basically saying yeah I know it says
this in the Bible but we've done this
for a long time so don't worry about it
they're just words well what's that
verse that says call no man father mhm
this is the one that he's quoting
actually right from Matthew
23 and and and there's no way around
that I mean
like Yeah so basically their reasoning
is is well these these Expressions have
evolved out of a long tradition and
because of that long tradition then well
then the Bible doesn't matter yeah you
you make God law void by your long
tradition but that that's their emmo the
whole time so it's not really surprising
that you see this title vicarious F de
you know all over it's used in tons of
their documents tons of their people and
then at some point later they're like no
no no no that's that's not a title we
never used that that that's you know and
they try to sweep it under the rug same
thing happened in the Protestant
Reformation you know it's like when all
the Protestant reformers are pointing to
Rome as the man of sin then they're like
okay what do we got to do uh the heat's
on uh let's come up with different
interpretations of Prophecy so we'll
have one of our guys write uh an
interpretation of Prophecy from
Revelation that says yeah all that's
already happened in the past we don't
need worry about that anymore and then
we'll have another one say all that
that's in the future it couldn't
possibly have anything to do with
anything now it's so far in the future
you don't need to worry about it it's
definitely not us so the heat's on again
yeah you know it as far as the usage
goes on different documents we've also
got this on for mdz uh this is the
decretum graani which you can find
multiple copies of this on the Vatican
Digital Library to this day where they
use the term and you see where the U
looks like a like a V looks like a u
right there so vicarius F de here's
another copy vicarius F de and the decum
graani you know this was canon law
something that we brought in previously
here we have an actual copy of this
right and you know this was commonly
used but the Authority for it was that
among the canonical scriptures the
decretal Epistles are co- enumerated so
their position was is that this is kind
of you know very much authoritative
canon law and their claims were to be
able to sit in that power seat Above the
Law of God and that they could dispense
Above the Law of God now weren't we
warned what's scripture were we warned
about where a power would think to
change times and laws that's spoken up
in Daniel Daniel 7 right and you know
this was part of what the Cardinals
claimed was that in Good Sense and
judgment Christ has given to Peter and
consequently to the Pope the power of
making that to be sin which is no sin
and that which is no sin to be
sin yeah innocent III in his transl
title 3 said that the pope is is said to
have a Heavenly power of determination
then therefore changes the nature of
things and that his will stands for Law
and that he can set free from the
obligation of the law and that he can
make just that which is unjust by
correcting and changing laws are you
going to go into what law they changed
well you know that's the thing is it's
times and laws right there's only one
commandment it's a fourth Commandment
and for those of you at home if you have
never heard of this before
um we've done a couple videos to show
you how the Sabbath biblical Sabbath was
changed to Sunday which was in honor of
the Roman son God I mean the Roman
Catholic Church came from Rome it
literally just translate just means
Roman Universal Church they came from
Pagan Rome and they they they were
worshiping the son and just to make it
easier on pagans son worshippers to
become Christians because now all of a
sudden Christianity was this like
Nationwide religion
they just said well yeah we'll just make
Sunday the day for worship there's
nothing there's no verse in the Bible at
all that you can prove that the Sabbath
was changed to Sunday in fact in the New
Testament um Sunday or the first day of
the week is only mentioned eight times
mhm and I believe it was five times that
it refer to the same Event Y so
technically that leaves you with three
more times that it was mentioned that
that there's actually four events that
Sunday was mentioned or first W week in
the New Testament and Sabbath is
mentioned I don't know how many times in
book of Acts alone like 30 something
times the book of Acts I think it's N I
thought it was nine nine times in act
but it look like 30 something or
something in the whole new testament so
I mean links in the description for you
to watch any of other videos on this or
just look it up for yourself but
honestly look into this and the Roman
Catholic Church themselves say we have
the authority we actually change Sabbath
to such
so they say once again you know that
they can dissolve by Divine Authority
that the pope is of so great Authority
and power that he is able to modify
declare or interpret even Divine laws so
if that's the case it negates the need
for Christ to die because if the law of
God is changeable exactly then why would
Christ have to come and die exactly
because sin is a transgression of the
law and Jesus came to save us from sin
right well that kind of goes to an
argument you know actually I had
recently where the Catholic was saying
that Christ did not die for you but for
the
penalty so it wasn't it was basically to
commute the the penalty but it wasn't
actually you know taking your place on
the cross it was anyhow it was it was
interesting but well what's the penalty
all about who who would get the penalty
if he didn't do it yeah that that was
those are some of my questions yeah
those were some of my questions but um
you know this was a canon in Tradition
right here where Carl Julius Holtzman
actually recognized that the authority
of the church could therefore not be
bound to the authority of the scriptures
because the church had changed
circumcision into baptism Sabbath into
Sunday not by the command of Christ but
by its own authority okay this is
fascinating because um when you look at
when you look at scripture there's a lot
of things that we
say in Christianity there're like oh
well that's that's changed or we don't
we don't do that anymore a lot of times
this is applied to the Sabbath like okay
well this is this is done away with you
know was nailed to the cross Etc so it's
it's it's gone fascinating thing about
circumcision we'll often times look at
circumcision like well that's not really
valid or applicable anymore
either however Paul makes it clear and I
think it's in the book of
Hebrews it's not that circumcision the
necessity for circumcision has
changed it's the location for where
circumcision happens is changed right so
he says the circumcision should be of
the heart amen okay the same idea
applies to the law of God it's not about
this outward external form as much as as
it's supposed to take up hold of your
heart we also know that from the book of
Hebrews and I think it was quoting from
Jeremiah if I'm remembering right but it
says that God's law should be written on
our heart so in other words the location
of where it's written has changed but
the law itself has not changed so
similar type idea with circumcision and
with the law of God it's not that
they've completely been erased it's that
the Loc ation where they're written or
performed has changed to the heart
instead so we don't want a form of
godliness and deny the power thereof no
you
know you know I I would say that uh uh
you know holtzman's idea here is not
just his own personal idea but this goes
back to the Council of Trent we've
talked about this before that there was
very much an admission that this power
that claims to take the place of the Son
of God also has has claimed power to
change his law mhm and you know if we go
back to the warning it's a warning in
Revelation 13 and 14 to not worship the
Beast MH don't take the name of the
Beast don't take the uh you know don't
make an image to the Beast and also
don't have his Mark and worship the
image of the Beast and let me warn you
that there's a power coming that will
try to change times and laws right now
what are those four warnings
Beast image name and Mark correspond to
in God's
law think about it false worship of a
beast violates worship God according to
Bible prophecy in Daniel you can read a
beast is a kingdom right and then don't
make an image to the Beast would violate
commandment too don't take the name of
the Beast because if you do that you're
going to take God's name in vain and
that's commandment three mhm so then
what is the mark of the beast all about
it goes back to commandment four MH and
also um understanding that if uh if does
God have a mark right in the Bible does
God have a and and I think it was token
seal Mark and there's one more that are
all kind of interchangeably used in the
Bible um and yeah if you look that up
it's the Sabbath Ezekiel 20:20
20:2 Exodus
31:17 again where God's sign is the 7th
Day Sabbath and then what's interesting
is in it's Exodus 139 and Deuteronomy 6:
6-8 that sign is connected to your hand
and your forehead this is the frontal
lob is your part of your brain that you
used to actually make decisions and to
worship and it's a seed of morality and
the will and this if and we could
probably throw some verses on the screen
your hand in the Bible frequently refers
to action to doing something so how is
it
connected well it's connected putting
you on the spot yeah it's connected CU
if you go back to uh well if you go back
to Catholic catechism
2176 they Institute a counterfeit sign
and they even call Sunday the sign the
mark of their Authority yeah so if it's
this counterfeit sign that God just got
done saying that he wants his sign on
our hand and our forehead in Exodus 139
that he wants his law to mark our
thoughts and our actions if they have a
counterfeit sign set up where's that
logically going to be placed it's going
to be placed on your hand and on your
forehead well Ezekiel talks about the
mark that saves yeah in Ezekiel 9
Ezekiel has this life-saving sign and he
defines what that is in Ezekiel 20:2 and
20:20 but the highest abomination in
Ezekiel 8 is Sun worship yeah yeah and I
was and and so that I'm not being obuse
the connection I was trying to make is
you're talking about Deuteronomy 6 where
they're supposed to put all these words
mhm you know talk with them with their
children when they go by the way when
they rise up and all that
and but what words and if and if you
just look at the previous chapter the
whole Ten Commandments had just been
spoken so in context it's those words
that God just gave them that he spoke
that he said here's my law now this is
what you're supposed to meditate on this
is what you're supposed to talk about
this is what you're supposed to
essentially bind in your hand as an
action or think about yeah in your
forehead those words and the sad reality
is that there are many people who look
at the Mark these days as like a chip a
barcode and RFID code you got 666 on
your license plate that's it right but
the sad reality is is the apostate Jews
read Exodus 139 and Deuteronomy 6 and
thought well what we need to do is we
need to take God's law and literally
wrap
we need to have fies around our heads
and that's sufficient even when we go
and kill Messiah right they go and kill
Christ and they break the law but oh if
they've got the felter then they're good
and then Christ speaks out against that
he says they make broad their fla trees
and enlarge the borders of their
garments and so he's speaking against
the hypocrisy of claiming that they're
you know keeping God's law and that
they're doing everything they should
when in reality their lives are a wreck
yeah and and and Jesus Jesus says this
is the Fulfillment of the law love man
love God you know it's about loving your
neighbor it's about but those two
Commandments right there right love God
and love your fellow man the first four
of the 10 teach us how to love God in
the last six teach us how to love our
fell man so he wasn't saying like oh
there's no more Ten Commandments no he
says this is the essence of the Ten
Commandments and everyone listening to
him was like astonished like man like
you you read instances of how they were
astonished at his doct CU he knew it so
well he understood the depth of it yeah
and also adding to what you said earlier
God says I do not want your sacrifices
just like just going through the motions
right like I'm just going to slaughter
this animal and I'm good you know just
like what they're doing is putting the
law on the forehead or their hand like
I'm good God says I want a relationship
with you yep and this the the sacrifices
that were happening in the Bible we're
just pointing forward to the Messiah
that was going to come who's going to be
sacrificed for us as a lamb slain for
the world the Bible says take no no
pleasure in the in the um or the the
sacrificing of bulls and goats like
there's no remission of sins yeah on
that because it's only when it points
forward to Christ and having putting
your faith in him and putting Faith it's
it's righteousness by faith yeah there's
a a story in Deuteronomy or not
Deuteronomy numbers 15 I like to bring
to people's
attention it's a lot of things in the
Bible that are done as Memorial morial
later and then people forget the reason
for the
memorial there's a guy who's out the
Sabbath commandment has already been
established and there's a guy who goes
out in the wilderness and he starts
gathering firewood on the Sabbath day
mhm and he goes and then he's caught and
the people bring him to Moses and
they're like we got this guy who is
gathering wood like what do we do and
Moses is like I don't know let me ask
God and God says Stone
him like everybody's just supposed to
Stone him like just just like that and
I'm like people look at that story like
man God is just
harsh really harsh right like that guy
is effectively executed for going out
and picking up wood on the
Sabbath why he had a rebellious heart
it's essentially what we're getting when
you read between the lines did he know
was he aware about the Sabbath
commandment yes and he was like don't
care it's kind of like my way it's kind
of like aen it is very much like aen
he's like doesn't matter I'm going to do
it my way well there was something that
came out of that story to remind the
children of Israel of this
event and so it
says um speak to the children of Israel
this is numbers yeah 15 37 tell them to
make tassels on the corner of their
garments throughout their generations
and put put a blue thread in the tassels
of the corners and you shall have the
tassel that you may look upon it and
remember what remember what tells us
Commandments all the Commandments of the
Lord and do them that you may not follow
the heart a tree which your own heart
and your own eyes are inclined and that
you may remember to do all the
Commandments and be holy for the Lord
your God I am the Lord who God who
brought you out of the land of Egypt to
be your God I am the Lord your God so
you have a blue thread there that is
being put in the borders of their
garments after the Sabbath is
broken so then you think about it today
we have laws today called blue laws
called blue laws I'm wondering if
there's any wonder wonder where that
idea came from but you know there's
there's something else too it was it was
put in the borders the fringes of the
Garment the fringes the canaf was
symbolic of the law but if you go to
Psalms
91 there's this promise about protection
when the plagues are falling and you
know when people on Thousand are dying
at thy hand and 10,000 at thy right hand
it shall not come nigh thee
but the the protection under the shadow
of the almighty under the canaf under
the wings of the
almighty the wings the
canaf uh if you think about the old Old
Testament Sanctuary where the Ten
Commandments were it was right
underneath the wings of the seraphim you
know right right there in in the the Ark
of the Covenant the
protection while the seven last plagues
are falling is found in the Ark of the
Covenant in other words by faith
entering with Christ through the Holy
Experience the Most Holy Experience all
the way in there to obedience to God's
Commandments having that that tassel
that that
symbol of obedience there it makes you
wonder how much of that was was Jesus
kind of alluding to and he's like
Jerusalem Jerusalem I would have
gathered you together as a hen gathers
its chicks under its wings you know yes
yep so yeah fascinating fascinating
stuff and the Ark everything in the ark
was about remembrance everything just
different lessons of remembrance
remember this remember this and remember
this so we have a message uh that we
want to leave you with called uh it I've
put in the Latin here
ex since we've been talking about so
many Latin documents but uh the message
in Revelation is come out of her my
people MH and so that's that's a message
that we continue today you know this
purple and Scarlet Harlot there's so
many churches out there that accept her
teaching some way or another and
especially when it comes to matters of
authority changes Protestant churches
too yeah exactly there's many that
accept her Authority but there's a
message in re revation to come out of
her my people yeah Beware Of The
ecumenical message don't don't follow it
you know stand true for what God's word
says and don't try to unite for the sake
of unity throwing aside the scriptures
and the truth stand on the truth and if
that causes Discord let it cause Discord
Jesus wants to unite unite Us in truth
which is the scriptures not let's set
aside all truth to come back to the
mother Church well I think that's a
really powerful
message I think it's also a really
somber message you know we are living in
a time when these things are happening
and I think that there's I always make
this statement there's a lot of really
beautiful Catholic people who are in the
Catholic Church who don't know about
this I I was actually baptized into the
Catholic Church as a baby I went the
sprinkling I went through communion
classes I was given a rosary my
grandparents were catholic uh later on I
became a Protestant Christian and um you
know now I'm and in this seat sharing
this with love to our Catholic brothers
and sisters and to Protestants who might
uh have some admiration for this system
um to share what prophecy is telling us
now for those of you at home if you've
seen this and you're more curious about
why 666 what does the Bible say about
that we have a whole video out it's only
I don't know maybe 30 minutes on what
the mark of the beast is we have a video
out maybe 30 minutes on what the
Antichrist is and we go verse by verse
by verse very in-depth we also have a
couple videos that James did with how
the Sabbath historically was changed to
Sunday I also want to recommend to you
guys the documentary by a Ministry
called amazing facts Revelation the
bride the beast in Babylon where they go
very in- depth into the history of Rome
and how it actually became the Roman
Catholic church and also talking about
the Fulfillment of it in Prophecy and
also make sure you guys check out James
and Alex's channels we'll put a link for
that in the description as well they go
very much into these kind of things and
they've bought tons of books from you
know the the Roman Catholic Church the
Jesuits which is a secret society of the
Vatican and they show you all of those
things on their own channels and uh Link
in the description as well for some of
the other episodes we've done with these
two gentlemen thank you guys so much for
watching if you want to support the work
that we do please go to
llsv or
patreon.com Studios or you can support
us buy buying yourself a hoodie or a
t-shirt he's wearing one right now
referring to Jesus as the Solid Rock
Amen to that you can get any of our
merch Christian merch at lightwear do
shop and that's a wrap for today and
we'll see you guys next week
[Music]
oh